iced tea seemingly claps back at critics
following this video shared by his wife
Coco Austin on social media
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome at the Holiday party the
couple's daughter Chanel really gets
into the spirit
I mean I and like this or my real life
doll I get to dress her up and we get to
match all day it's funny I didn't even
think I was going to be like that parent
but I turned into one and apparently
certain people took issue with the
seven-year-olds dancing and the response
may have inspired ice tea to post this
message to the gram quote everyone is
going to hate you anyway so you might as
well give them a reason the rapper
doubles down in the caption adding quote
my advice is you go into 2023 with this
attitude if you want to win back in
Coco's original post she explained that
Chanel was channeling Tina from Bob's
Burgers oh my God Coco recalled quote
the adults in our family were doing a
tick tock and Chanel runs out in the
middle to bust the move to make us laugh
yes
the controversy follows previous online
Jabs that some of Coco's parenting
choices like bathing Chanel in the
kitchen sink and pushing her in a
stroller which Coco's haters claim she
was too old for in the aftermath Coco
tweeted quote Oh Lord really people the
world loves to criticize literally
everything I do
[Music]
well if iced tea is publicly defending
his wife it wouldn't be the first time
you just want a little love you want a
little disrespect from people the
reality star appeared on chairman Hall
last month where she got a special shout
out from hubby you are the most
incredible person I ever met the nicest
person I ever met and the best mother to
shoot now that anyone who could possibly
imagine you don't hear the goodness you
just hear a lot of bad and I know I'm a
good mother because of my dedicated last
six years of putting everything aside my
career everything just for her
foreign
[Music]